hello everyone uh we are well we are
with wytek today and he will be speaking
on how to detect silent model failures
oh that seems like an interesting topic
everybody's everybody wants to you know
uh have a notification or update off
when their models are failing or when
there's something going on in their
hands so yeah i think this would be a
nice presentation and
over to you and could you please start
with a short intro for
sure thanks a lot sanket uh it's
pleasure to be here uh so yeah my name
is moyte kuberski i'm one of the
co-founders of nannyml uh which is a
machine learning monitoring startup we
are operating across europe and what
we're trying to do is basically protect
the impact that your models uh have
right now in your organization
i'm a technical guy my background is
machine learning uh i did my master's in
belgium at k11 then i used to i started
a consultancy and then i moved to a
startup and i have to admit that startup
life is really cool life but it's a lot
of work so
that's me in a nutshell
is it okay if i started presentation
second
yes yes
okay perfect so uh what we're gonna talk
about today is detecting silent machine
learning failure um in other words
something that's called model
performance monitoring uh so without
further ado let's get going so what's on
the agenda today uh we're going to start
with the
end in mind so what happens when the
model fails and we're going to talk
about what causes that which is the
concept drift and the data and of course
the results of that which tend to be
disastrous
then we're going to talk about once we
define constitution data we're going to
talk about how to detect it in real life
systems i'm going to start with very
simple techniques we'll give a quick
overview of simple techniques and then
we're going to go over some more robust
approaches that tend to work a bit
better
then we're going to move yet a step
further and we're going to talk about
using machine learning to predict
performance and estimate performance
using the signals from data and concept
of detection even if we don't have
access to ground troop data
which of course allows us to estimate
performance of your machine learning
models in production and if something
goes wrong take actions then we're gonna
tie it all together we'll go back to
business and uh we'll talk about how to
make sure that the impact of your models
is protected
and then we're gonna have a very quick
slide about how to implement it in your
organization
uh from a bit more engineering
perspective
so let's get going
uh to set the stage uh we're gonna
always think about an example use case
in this example use cases let alone
default prediction case uh where we take
as model inputs the credit scores and
customer information and what we are
trying to predict is whether pressing
defaults or not on a loan
uh so we're going to assume that this is
a long term loan when non-payment is
defined basically default is defined as
a non-payment within first year
we of course need to have a business
metric in mind and this is going to be
risk adjusted return on investment it's
just a typical metric that people in
industry use to measure the impact of
their models and then of course we need
to have a technical metric that kind of
links back to the business and for that
we're gonna again go with standard f
beta score and for those of you who are
not familiar with what a beta store is
there is a quick definition here below
so that is an example that we're just
going to keep on referring to throughout
the presentation
uh so let's start with what happens when
models fail uh let's start with the data
and define what data drift is so data
drift is simply the change in joint
probability distribution of the model
inputs so let's assume that we have a
reference period which could be either
training period one of the first periods
in production can be a week a month now
depending on the volume of your data
and we have a current period current
period is something that we are
currently experiencing and we want to
see what is the performance and where
there is data drift during current
period and again this kind of thinking
last week last month uh whatever you
choose
uh so uh here it is this very simple
visualization when you see one
dimensional model input
and we have a
density function here and we see it's
changing so the more significant this
change is the stronger is the data
it's as simple as that there is really
nothing magical about it
so now let's talk about the second
concept that we'll have to introduce
here which is the concentric so the
concept drift is simply the change in
the mapping between the target and the
model inputs so assuming that we have a
certain number of model inputs we're
trying to learn the underlying real
function that maps the model inputs to
the target
and of course this can change in time uh
due to mostly external factors uh things
that are not observed in the data so
again let's just imagine that we have a
training data set and the real
underlying
kind of
boundary between people who default and
people who don't who do not default is
this great line here
and as time passes maybe because
customer preferences change or they
become more or less risk proud
we can see simply change in this
boundary so people who normally be
unlikely to uh
default they become more and more likely
to default and you shouldn't be giving
them loads
uh so that's cons again nothing special
but there's of course few intricacies
here uh so what we could have is
kind of concept group that is induced by
data
so again
say definition stays the same but it
doesn't necessarily be just the external
factors that create concept drift it can
be also just data due to within
uh the data set so imagine that we have
two classes right people who uh will
default the positives so the light blue
here and people who will not default so
the negatives the purple color and
we train a machine learning model and we
decide that the optimum boundary is here
and for our business this is indeed the
optimum boundary
but now as time passes we will see that
there is more and more people who will
not default maybe people become richer
maybe they become
more risk-averse
and that means that the actual optimal
boundary can already change just because
our metric is
measured in a way and optimized for
slightly non-linear behavior in the data
so we had the old optimal boundary here
but the new optimal boundary is here
so in that case we should do something
because our models are technically not
providing less value but we are not
extracting as much volume
from our models as we could if we had
properly monitored our machine learning
production
so that's kind of the overview of
concept drift and data drift is
and now
let's talk about slightly different view
of machine learning that will help us
later on uh have a kind of fresh look at
concept drift and data drift
so
we're going to talk about kind of the
bayesian network kind of approach to
modeling
real life behavior
and specifically we're going to focus on
the networks when we do not have access
to every variable that actually causes
the target or is caused by the target
so imagine network on the left is
something that we
would observe in reality if we had
access to everything this is the
underlying round truth of what is
happening with the target so maybe our
long default prediction is caused
partially by
how much people make but maybe also by
some internal psychological factors that
of course we do not have direct access
to or some factors that we only have
secondary access to like here
uh so of course we cannot model it fully
and everything that's not modeled will
be treated as a noise because we cannot
really understand what's going on so to
use a very simple simplistic even
approach to machine learning let's just
imagine that
we have these variables and they fit
using
arbitrary complex function which could
be a neural network or whatever you
please and they will try to fit into the
model and they will then create in
practice in in production they will
create more predictions and of course we
are losing some information here just
because we don't have access to it we
cannot access it because it's not in the
data and this has some
foraging consequences
so let's talk about data drift in this
looking from this perspective so here
the data drift is simply change in the
observed variables because we define
data drift as change in the inputs it's
of course something that we can observe
so far so good but now let's look at the
concept before we're talking about the
concept of being the change in the
mapping but if you look at the left side
here
the mapping can be fully defined by just
looking at the input data and the output
data
because literally nothing else here can
influence the target
everything else
will be basically stemming from these
three variables
so what you could say is that instead of
looking at considering change of mapping
it concept drift can be also defined as
data drift and unobserved variables
because that will look as if the mapping
between the
model inputs and the target is changing
but actually the only thing that's going
to change is how the unobserved
variables behave and how they influence
the target and this is something you
cannot observe directly which is the
main reason of course why it's so hard
to predict the performance of machine
learning models in production and it's
so hard to detect concentric
which is going to be the main focus of
the rest of the presentation
so let's start first quickly data drift
detection as it is something that we
need to build upon to really go to the
end goal which is performance prediction
here i'm gonna only focus on two
kind of maybe not main but most adopted
uh detections are methods detect data
drift so the
simplest one that has many shortcomings
but it's reasonably easy to implement is
statistical tests so what we're going to
do is we're going to
look always at the reference periods to
something that has happened in the past
and we know the performance of this past
period which could be last month or it
could be the first month of production
and or could be even the training period
if we do not have access to any labels
in production
and
we will run simple either universe or
multivariate tests on the input data
such as ks test uh which simple
visualization you have here so basically
quick overview of what ks does is we're
trying to see whether the
reference period and the current period
have statistically significant different
distributions
so we're going to look at the cumulative
probability distribution and we're going
to compute the statistical statistic
which is just basically the maximum
difference between
the height of this line
and the height of this line for any of
the of the x values
um
very simple stuff these are just
physical test for uh non-continuous
volumes for categorical variables you
would use chi-squared test which
probably most of you are already
familiar with and there are some other
uh
approaches that sometimes try to take
all the variables at once but they still
have very strong assumptions such as
maximum loan discrepancy
unfortunately i don't have a few hours
to go in depth into all of those uh so
let me just say that this desk has have
uh lots of problems when it comes to the
assumption so a simple thing is that if
you just run ksbs on every single
feature you assume that they are
independent and you will not really look
into how the correlations or
dependencies between the input variables
are changing which could of course very
strongly influence the performance of
your model because they are also modeled
by more advanced machine learning
systems
so now we're going to look at the second
part which is slightly more advanced and
in
our experience tends to work reasonably
well on all kinds of data so we're gonna
look at measure of a data drift which is
reconstruction error of either
dimensional deduction techniques mindful
learning techniques or some
same to say mappings like variational
autoencoders
so what we're going to do
let me take a variation out encoder as
an example here so what we're going to
do is we're going to take the
original data set so the light blue here
and the reference period and we're going
to train a variation out encoder on it
which means that of course we create a
bottleneck in the data i'm sorry the
network has a bottleneck and it's trying
to land compressed representation of the
data and this compressed representation
of the data uh of course and caused the
structure of the data because we cannot
have a
general compressor that works on all
kinds of data the compression is only
possible if the data is redundant or if
we can model the structure of the data
so here
we will use the reduced space
and then we're gonna go back to the
original space so we're gonna
reconstruct uh the
uh
inputs from the inputs using of course
the bottleneck
and
on the reference period we expect it to
work reasonably well because the model
trains to optimize and then we're gonna
use the same network that is trained on
the reference period
and we're gonna try to reconstruct new
inputs and if these inputs are
reasonably close and the manifold on the
uh on which the data lies is the same or
very close to the manifold that the
reference period data lies
then
uh we should be able to reconstruct the
new data without too much error so the
construction error is gonna be low
however if the data has changed and the
manifold is different
then it's gonna be
quite hard for the network to
reconstruct the data correctly and we're
gonna expect high reconstruction error
which leads us to just having
reconstructioner as a good metric that
not only shows whether the data exists
or not but also the magnitude
and let's talk about pca as an example
another example and let's go a bit more
in depth again
so let's start with quick assumptions of
pca so first of all we need to assume
that the linear data transformation is
appropriate for our data set and we need
to assume that the mean and variance are
the reasonably sufficient statistics to
represent
the data
and that orthogonal principle components
are again a reasonable transformation of
the data it doesn't need to be perfect
but it needs to be good enough as you
probably know in practice pca is a
reasonable again dimensionality
reduction technique
uh even if some of the assumptions are
violated so we're gonna do what i just
described we're gonna train the pca
we're gonna fit the pca on our reference
period and then we're going to use
this fit
pca to try to reconstruct the data over
time so imagine that we have a training
period we have validation period and we
have three production periods and what
we can expect
is that as data
slightly changes in time we're going to
have some variance in the reconstruction
error it tends to increase immediately
just because there might be some
kind of randomness and observed things
in the data that influences randomness
and then it's gonna stabilize until
there is data and funny thing that we
observe is that of course as the
reconstruction error increases we can
expect data drift but also if the
reconstruction error decreases it means
that data becomes maybe even more linear
or more condensed
and which actually results in
decreasing reconstruction error which is
also a very strong signal for data drift
this is simple
but reasonably well working data
detection technique
that can kind of serve as the first idea
if you were to implement data to
detection yourself that is something i
would recommend doing it's simple it
doesn't take much time it doesn't take
much optimization and it will get you
let's say 50 percent there to really be
good at data detection
but of course data drift does not
necessarily mean model failure and let's
talk about it here so uh we have four
visualizations here the first
two left ones are just example of a
training data and the production data
and if we see no concept drift it's not
induced by data drift in any way then we
can expect our mode to perform still
reasonably well even though there is
for example less data in this part
compared to this part now
but if data drift in some way induces uh
concept drift
that means that the decision boundary
changes so the decision boundary but i
was trained by the model is no longer
appropriate and we can expect the model
to make more mistakes so that can result
in model failure
and
of course we could just instead of doing
all that we could just measure the
performance if we had ground truth
but the thing is we very rarely actually
do have full access to ground truth and
there's three reasons for that so first
of all in automation use case so the
case when trying to automate some kind
of work that was done by a human
uh
that's the point of machine learning use
case to not have to do it again manually
so the ground rule that people used to
provide manually will no longer be there
of course there are spot checks but we
can expect at most few percent of the
data to be available
then using our example uh use case
uh the ground truth tends to be delayed
uh so in in this case we have to wait
nine months to really get the ground
truth about whether people uh yeah
defaulted or not
and that is something that's not
acceptable we cannot really have model
running for nine months giving loans to
people without really knowing what's
going on and whether it's performing
well or not
and even if we do have labels quite
shortly after the
uh prediction is made they tend to be
incomplete imagine a churn model when
you actually never know whether the
person would have turned if you haven't
if you haven't acted on the churn
prediction when the person is predicted
to churn uh
then there's marketing campaigns maybe
some discounts applied and this person
maybe doesn't turn but you you will
never really know when this person would
have changed if you haven't had acted so
the labels are very complete
and because of that we need to try to
estimate performance of machine learning
models even without access to ground
truth because we never do have full
access to run through
so how do we go about it
first thing uh we could do
as we can just look at the regions of
the data
that uh the models performing well
versus the regions of the data where the
one is not performed well so on the
first block on the left here you see the
training period and the dots are just
data points and the
pilot place and the data the violent
block
is the place where the mall is uh
predicting very well it's very certain
about predictions and it generally
performs well the green part is the
place the reaching the data when the
model is not performed well and as time
passes two
or maybe other things can happen but of
course there's two example things that
can happen that will actually influence
the uh performance of the model one of
them is let's say that the data moves
from the region when it's performing and
when the model is performing well to the
region where the model is not performing
that well which we can detect and then
we can reasonably
stay or
quite high certainty we can say that the
performance of the model has decreased
and we can even measure this effect
another thing we can see is that there's
data drift from the regions when the
model really knows what's going on there
is a lot of data to train to the regions
in the input space when there is not
that many when we didn't have access to
many training examples like here
and then we cannot really say what is
the performance of the model we just can
say that the
we don't know what's going on and that
is something so the uncertainty of our
performance has increased significantly
which of course is also useful
now let's look at a concept drift a
prediction and i'm just gonna go over
very quickly and i will cover the
easiest way of doing that
which is let's assume that of course for
certain periods of production or certain
types of data we will have access to
ground truth we can measure it and then
we can use time series
techniques
to try to extrapolate it in the future
and that combined with our data
detection methods tends to give a pretty
good uh view on performance even if we
don't have access to ground
so now let's talk about actually putting
it all together
uh so what we do and probably that's uh
one of the more robust ways of detecting
performance is that we put the all the
data drift signals
we put our predicted concept drift and
we're also going to try to model kind of
the uh
the real life from bayesian perspective
we put it all in kind of the overarching
machine learning model that then it
tries to predict performance and
of model introduction
and if you take all of these um ideas
tied together as features in the model
then the model can pick the ones that
are most relevant and that increases
kind of the robustness of our machine
learning prediction
performance prediction system
but now let's say we all have this we
can predict performance and the question
is so what
uh so how do we actually take that into
something that provides value to the
business
so the first thing we should do i'm just
gonna walk you through the steps that
are necessary to provide value
first we need to predict or measure the
performance on the entire population
level or the entire sample level that we
have access to
and then we should also look at the
segments in the data that we
particularly care about just because the
performance and population level this
region unstable doesn't mean that there
might be some
you know there might be some
segment in the data that we particularly
care about maybe these are people that
provide more value to the business maybe
these are people that are very important
because they are outspoken we need to
look at these segments and we need to
see how these segments perform so we're
going to do the exact same thing that i
described
again
at segment level and then we're going to
see whether these things work or not
whether the performance of every segment
is still
reasonably high or whether it is
definitely
and then
what we should do next we know what has
happened but we don't really know how
and why it happened and what to do to
fix it so then we would need to go to
the root cause analysis and then we
would like to recommend such uh or
suggest proactive measures to really fix
the problem which might be as simple as
the training and as complex as
redeveloping the model because maybe the
relationships
that the data exhibits are no longer
uh
it cannot can no longer be won by the
existing
machine learning pipeline
i would love to go more in detail in the
root cause analysis and how to suggest
corrective measures but it's
unfortunately only a 20-something minute
presentation so i can do that here
so now slowly wrapping up
let's talk about how to implement it in
your organization
so quick overview of
how normally machine learning works so
we have a business process whatever it
might be it might be
giving loans to people
we have the customer environment that
you as people who create model
performance monitoring will be serving
which is basically data scientists that
develop these models
and we have the model input we have the
training data and the metadata and the
model output
and idea you would also like to have
access to the repository with kpis with
the ground roof and maybe some other
downstream data from that results from
the business process and the actions
that are taken
based on machine learning model
recommendations
and then at the end we would have our
performance monitoring system when we
have our processing pipelines probably
some notebooks to initial data
scientists what's going on so they can
quickly access that would like to have
integration apis and all the other
engineering things that are necessary
there
and of course we'd like to uh track it
in time uh
just to see how it performs in time
whether we should act or it's still okay
so these things tend to be stored in
some kind of time series database and
then we give it to business users data
people and machine learning operations
teams so they can act on it and make
sure that
the impact of machine learning models is
protected
and that's basically it here is there is
a few resources i will not go over them
i'm going to show the presentation
afterwards of course so you can look at
them if you are interested
and that's it thanks for listening and
if you'd like to learn more about it
feel free to either email me add me on
linkedin message me on linkedin and i'm
happy to answer any questions i will
also be in the slack uh chat after the
presentation so uh let's check there and
thanks everyone for listening that is it
thank you for the presentation uh it was
a wonderful one and uh we have a
question i think it was asked earlier in
the presentation uh i'm not sure if it
was covered or not but i'll still ask
you
uh the question is the drift is because
of external factors or not
ah so
uh maybe i'll go back to the real event
slide and talk about it so
what you can see here is basically
beijing network right and these are the
external factors these are the things
that cannot see
and these are the things that we can see
so
they are just features in our data set
and data drift as normally defined is
due to change of the observed variables
our features and concept drives so the
change in the mapping as you would see
in between the
model inputs and the target it's
normally due to the unobserved variables
but of course let's say that this
unobserved variable changes it is quite
likely that it changes because this
variable changes so there is a certain
uh relationship or correlation between
the data drift that we observed and also
concept group that stems from that so
it's always basic almost always a mix
between observed internal factors and
external factors if you are really
unlucky it might happen that there is
some external variable that you cannot
observe
in any way it's not correlated with any
of the things that you can observe this
variable changes influences the target
and then you just see a concept drift
without really seeing any data that is
something that's possible especially in
machine learning systems that are barely
better than random
because if machine learning model has
very high metrics it generally means
that most of the
information in the data that came from
information in the world that can
potentially
impact the target is already captured by
your system you have access to all
important variables
but if your model is barely better than
random it means that there is a lot of
unobserved variables that influence the
system so then you are also more likely
to experience constitute
i hope that answers your question
yeah uh so
let me so we do have a couple of
questions uh more than a couple of
questions for you uh the other question
is can you automate the model correction
sorry come
again can you automate the model
connection
yes so this is something that kind of
comes downstream from model monitoring
it's something that you can i would say
augment
and we are quite far from automating and
the way we go about it is that you can
easily integrate you know either our
solution or something that's homemade um
where you get signals for performance
you know the performance you can have
also the confidence buds on the
performance and once it grows
certain threshold when you know that the
impact of your model is at risk
you can trigger training and if you have
good root cause analysis and recommended
actions you can decide what has exactly
happened what variables change and then
you can take the actions sometimes the
access can they can fully automatically
if it's simple in training or maybe
dropping some data from the training
data set and training or maybe doing
some kind of correction some kind of
covariation in your training data
to account for data drift these systems
will be extremely complex but you can
automate them but sometimes
if the root cause of the problem is the
fact that there is a change in
unobserved variables you would need to
go and try to find what are other things
that are changing so i can fix my model
so in some cases you can fully automate
that sometimes you would for example
like to trigger spot checks in your
automation system so then people go and
manually inspect the data provide new
labels and then you will train and then
everything about from actually doing
small checks can be automated but the
spot checks themselves need to be manual
because you need to have ground floor
that's provided by humans
all right uh thank you vertec uh so we
are over the time but i can still take
one question uh so the next question is
and the question is which domains
frequently show concept drift
yeah that's a great question that's a
really interesting question so
uh from my experience
mostly everything that has to do with
tabular data will experience more drift
because you operate in high
noise kind of regimen if you work in
computer vision
uh the cat detection is a cat cat is
always a cat and the cats are will
continue to be cats if you try to depict
something in the image as long as it
keeps on looking the same to humans it
will keep them looking reasonably
similar to the machines
however
if you work with anything that has to do
with clients
anything that's customer facing
you tend to experience a lot of concept
drift and data drift there as people are
changing their preferences are changing
their behavior is changing so that i
would say is kind of the domain that
experiences the most uh data and concept
drift
finance
covers anything that deals with people
really
uh thank you for the answer vertec and i
think we are almost at the time so i
would like to thank waiter for coming
today and you know sharing and sharing
your knowledge with us and it was a
wonderful presentation
you